un contragolpe que escala las tensiones
que sancionó a nueve individuos y cuatro
organizaciones británicas en represalia
a medidas similares que había adoptado
reino unido junto a canadá eeuu y la
unión europea la disputa se da por las
presuntas vibraciones de derechos
humanos contra la minoría musulmana
uigur denuncias que bay sin califica de
mentiras la manchega ellos anuncian
sanciones contra china basados en
rumores mentiras e información falsa eso
es inaceptable para nosotros
ciertamente estamos forzados a llevar
adelante una justa necesaria y legítima
autodefensa che y moche en tanda para
wii entre las personas sancionadas
aparecen el líder del comité de asuntos
exteriores del parlamento británico tom
to benja y varios legisladores que han
cuestionado las acciones de china es
inicial incluyendo al ex líder
conservador
ian duncan smith
el primer ministro boris johnson
respaldo a los castigados y destacó su
rol esencial en sacar a la luz los
presuntos abusos una postura unánime en
el gobierno británico somos totalmente
solidarios con las nueve personas
sancionadas eso no nos detendrá ni
evitará que el gobierno británico hable
sobre las violaciones a los derechos
humanos a escala industrial que tienen
lugar en xinjiang según organizaciones
de derechos humanos y de exiliados más
de un millón de uigures han sido
recluidos por la fuerza en campos de
detención de xinjiang estas entidades
también acusan a las autoridades de
imponer trabajos forzados y
esterilizaciones obligatorias a las
mujeres beijing niegan las acusaciones y
asegura que ha implementado programas de
entrenamiento y trabajo y una mejor
educación para evitar el extremismo en
la región